i
le président Zelensky.
L'armée russe a pris
le contrleneuve raleneuve ralen.
(tirs)
- Après des jours d'intense
pilonnage, l'armée russe
a réussi à gagner la ville
en détruisant tous les ponts
qui y menaient encore.
L'armée ukrainienne vient
d'annoncer qu'elle a abandonné
aux forces russes.
"Les derniers soldats ukrainiens
encoreencoreencore sur place n'e
deux choix, dit ce représentant
des séparatistes pils doivent se
ou mourir."
Dans la ville voisine,
Lyssytchanks, on essaie
possible.
Tout comme à Pokrovsk, à une
centaine de kilomètres de là.
convergent chaque jour
pour mond de
l'un de ces trains gratuits,
en direction de Lviv,ys.
"Hier, notre maison a été
bombardé
terrifiés, dit cette femme;
alors noécidé
de partir."
Pendant nationale ukrainienne aé
enquêter sur la mort
de 12 000 de ses concitoyens
depuis le début du conflit.,
où des enquêteurs mettent
au jour une fosse commune.
"Les victimes avaient les mains
ce policier, et des traces
de balles dans les genoux
et dans la tête."
selon lui, que ces civils
ont été torturés atre
froidement abattus.